well i'm pleased to say that john
valentin the british diver who helped
lead that rescue joins us now live john
valentin thank you so much for being
with us
and well done on that rescue just just
talk us through those 18 days
morning it's nice to be here i think
they were a very fraught
period of time
it took a long time to find the children
but once we found them we had no idea at
that time how we were going to get the
boys out and that was perhaps the most
difficult part of the operation most
people in the press seem to think that
once we've found them it would be easy
but really the difficulties were just
starting but eventually we were able to
bring all of the boys
back to the surface
safely as well as the coach
and just reminders for for those um
watching that forgotten how this
happened how you managed to get involved
in this and also why it was that we had
to get divers to get these boys out of
the cave when they managed to obviously
they didn't swim in they walked in
so the boys walked into the cave and
then unfortunately due to heavy rainfall
the cave flooded behind them
and so there was eventually a mile or
1500 meters of completely flooded
passage separating the chamber where
they were sheltering
separating them there from the exit and
so it was necessary
to dive them back out through that mile
of flooded passages and that was why
essentially we needed divers i'm a
member of a cave rescue organization in
the uk and i tend to specialize in in
cave diving and this was one of those
very difficult or unusual situations
that required
our expertise
yeah it was just an incredible moment i
remember it very well and i'm sure that
it it kind of put us in a position of
when we're trying to rescue those
chilean miners as well we're just
waiting and waiting and hoping that you
guys would be able to do it eventually
you did i mean describe what it was like
when you finally managed to get through
to those lads
when we when we found the boys i was a
long way beyond what would normally be
considered acceptable safety margins in
cave diving and so i was very focused on
my survival at that time making sure i
could make my exit
but immediately we found the boys
everything changed and rather than being
worried about myself
i now had to be worried about the boys
and try to be thinking about their
welfare and worrying about how we were
going to work with them to reassure them
to give them some sense that we were
going to be able to get them out
and john i thought on the film depicting
the rescue uh is it any good
i think the film is amazing the
underwater cinematography especially is
absolutely outstanding and
i think ron howard and the whole team
have done a really good job of capturing
what i felt was the most important part
of the rescue the concept of teamwork
the idea that all of these organizations
from different nations all came together
with a single shared goal and we were
able to bring all of the boys out by
working closely with one another
and finally then john just talk to us a
little bit about the work that you're
doing to sort of maintain that idea of
teamwork and making sure that people
stay safe when they do take part in
these kind of activities
i realized that most of my
lessons that i've learned in cave diving
could be transferred both to normal life
and also to the workplace and so i've
been involved with a leadership course
with edapp and
we've put this online and it's available
for free
to to allow people really to get a sense
hopefully of some of the lessons and
some of the
techniques that i've learned over the
years to be able to cope better not just
with cave diving and cave rescue
situations but also situations you find
perhaps in the workplace or also just
that we encounter in everyday life